we're joined now by CBS News contributor
Abram X Ken D he's founding director of
the anti-racist research and Policy
Center at American University Abram is
also the creator of the Cova Dre shil
data tracker Abram welcome to start with
tell us what what the data tracker is
trying to do well first it's a
collaboration between the coded tracking
project as well as my colleagues at the
the anti-racist research and Policy
Center and we're seeking to collect
ingest produce make available racial
data that's being released by states all
over this country so about 30 more than
30 states have released data on either
infection rates or death rates and we
want to collect that data and make it
available to people but then analyze it
and then report it out tell the story
about what's happening in our country
there's it surprise you that that data
hasn't really effectively been collected
already so it was surprising certainly
at the beginning of this month very few
states had released any sort of racial
demographic data on who was being
infected and who was dying and even
being hospitalized as a result of kogut
19 and so many people and including
myself we started calling for that data
and and as I stated dozens of state says
have released it but we want all states
to release it and we're in every County
to release it and we want to really get
a picture of who's most vulnerable
because it appears in in many states
black Americans in particular are dying
at double the rate of their population
in other words the percentage of the
black people who are dying are typically
double their population percentage in
many states
why do you in from what do you think
that is and and and how do you think it
needs to be addressed well I think the
most immediate reason is because black
people are more likely to suffer from
pre-existing condition
like heart disease and respiratory
disease in asthma but the reason there's
a series of reasons why black people are
more likely to to suffer these
pre-existing conditions they're more
likely to live in food deserts they're
more likely live in trauma deserts
they're less likely to have access to
high-quality care there's studies of
showing a relationship between racism
and stress levels so there's a series of
reasons and that's what we need to be
studying but we also need to be ensuring
that this extremely vulnerable
population is being protected and
resources of being put for to ensure
that they are receiving high-quality
life-saving care your wife Abram is a
doctor working on the frontlines right
now how have you been impacted by by the
virus I mean I mean obviously there are
medical providers all over this country
who who are currently heroes and and my
wife is one of them she's an ER doctor
in Washington at a Children's Hospital
and in children's hospitals are now
typically serving all over this country
older people as as she is she's taking
care of coded patients I've had to watch
her put on her personal protective
equipment and and take it off and worry
about whether she's been infected and
worried about her patients who she knows
have been but I've also watched as her
hometown of Albany Georgia in southwest
Georgia has become one of the outbreak
zones for coltd 19 has one of the
highest death rates in the country and
her parents they lived there and so
she's received port reports of friends
from high school and and and older
people who are dying or who who are
suffering from this disease and so it
feels like an everyday thing for us yeah
well it's really important this data
gets related collected there is no
federal system to collect it Ibrahim X
Kennedy thank you very much